hello everyone and welcome to another
most impressive game from the 23rd
european team championship that's
currently being played it's a viktor
erdos hungarian grand master versus uh
not bador joe bava
sorry about that that's from the
previous video let me just fix that
there we go
a few seconds there we go
all right
so all it is
with the black pieces and it's quite an
impressive game it's you know it has
everything it uh
if you've seen the thumbnail you know
that crazy uh stuff is happening uh from
the beginning and it's uh well um
a very important game for uh alireza's
onslaught onto the world top five uh as
you know he overtook nepal in the live
ratings then he fall back then he again
overtook nepal in round one of this of
this tournament
and now he wants to remain there and
hopefully even overtake fabi as fabi is
currently
world number three so let's see how this
is going as this is an incredible uh
incredible game and it's not an easy one
well to win uh so let's check it out
after with the white pieces opens with
e4
we have c6 sorry about that alireza goes
for the karo khan defense we have knight
to f3 and d5 uh striking in the centers
and knight to c3 now defending the e4
pawn and the bishop to g4 going for the
mundane variation uh we have h3 and the
bishop capture so black gives up the
bishop pair very early on uh queen
captures and now e6 and now all your
pawns are on light squares you don't
have a light square bishop so nothing to
worry about we have d four by white
grabbing more space in the center and
knight to f6 uh putting pressure on that
e for pawn and usually uh white will
play something like bishop to g5 or
bishop to d3 adding another defender to
the e4 pawn but here we have e captures
on d5 and this is um
well not something that you would expect
because there has to be a justification
for a capturing chess and here
it's not easy to find one uh so okay oh
it is a character c captures on d5 we
have bishop to d3 now and now uh you
have the c6 square available for your
knight so all it is it just develops
it's the c6 so knight to c6 comes with
tempo as the d4 pawn is attacked so
knights to e2 defending this preparing
c3 and we have h6 now preventing bishop
to g5 we have c3 and bishop to d6 uh now
saying that okay i might be castling
king's side but also many other things
are possible
and there is one game where knight the
g3 was played it was played in 1978 uh
but here we have bishop to c2 by erdog
and it is now only as of move 11 that we
have a completely new game so alersa has
to
continue developing uh and how do you
develop do you castle king side that is
of course possible and then we have um
well then we have a game but uh with the
d3 square now already being freed for
the white queen uh it would be maybe a
bit counterintuitive
to uh castle king sided at this point so
it is a goes for a different idea rook
the c8 he leaves the king in the center
of the board uh and says all right this
rook might be very useful here and your
bishop is on sea to undefend it so who
knows if this knight moves we might even
have some knight capture some d4 ideas
uh in the position uh so erdos goes g4
prepares g5 here and now
again what do you play well now you're
definitely not castling king side
because white already said that he will
not be castling kingside and that uh you
might expect an attack here so all it is
starts with king the d7 it's the move
from the thumbnail and it is how we
castle in modern chess so there's no
need to castle we can just waste three
moves and then uh bring our king to
safety this is what all it is a place
king the d7 and there doesn't seem to be
a way to take advantage of this uh well
uh brilliant move
right away so here we have g5 continuing
this attack with h captures bishop
captures now the knight is pinned and
the king to c7
we have queen side castles and the now
king to b8 and now both kings are nicely
uh tucked in all the way on the queen
side and the game continues we have rook
d to g1 and now you might expect all
right the kings are now on the queen
side we're going to have a nice game on
the king side you know things will be
pushed pieces will will be traded off
but not really
alireza plays b5
he wants to play a5 b4 and start an
attack against the white king on the
queen side so a3 preventing b4 for the
moment and alireza just continues with
a5 we have queen to d3 attacking that b5
pawn and just queen to b6 defending the
pawn uh we have bishop captures on f6
you could also play something else you
don't really have to capture the knight
but the knight coming to e4 might be a
bit of a problem then the f2 pawn is
attacked and it's just a you know if you
just imagine this knight on e4 it's it's
so ugly you don't even want to imagine
it so it's better to just get rid of it
right away so g captures on f6 and rook
to g7 so now we have a very active rook
here and we have to defend our f7 pawn
or maybe we don't but uh you know
that's what you first uh think about
when you're when someone attacks your
pawn so we could defend it with
something like rook to c7 we could start
the attack immediately with b4 and say
i'm not interested in defending that
doubled f7 pawn uh or you could uh
defend with the queen so alerissa
decides to defend with the queen now the
queen is a bit overstretched guarding on
b5 and on f7 but for the moment there
doesn't seem to be a way for white to
take advantage of this so here we have
rook h the g1
and now we uh continue the attack b4
so what can y2 do here well uh there are
a couple of options here one a very good
option is to just capture for example a
captures on b4 a captures and now bishop
to a4 uh so we get the b5 square
available for our queen for example
knight a5 queen b5 uh and now we force a
queen ray let's say captures captures
and now we bring this rook uh at
f8 to defend the f7 pawn and the game
continues however black should always be
a little bit better here uh if uh you
know if nothing he has less pawn islands
and you know the rook still being in the
game uh these pawns are are somewhat
weak and the pressure on the position is
definitely in black's favor so instead
after b4 white decided to keep uh the
tension a little bit he played a4
and now bishop to f8 alersa chases this
rook back and you can't really play rook
to g8 because of this ugly bishop to h6
check move for example we just straight
bishop to h6 check and we pick up the
rook here
so that loses the game on the spot so
instead we have rook to h7 and now
bishop to h6 with check we have king to
d1 you could also go to b1 but that just
looks ugly with the queen being on b7
and all so f5 now disconnecting the
queen's defense of the rook on h7 you
have to trade here h captures a real
captures uh on h8 with rook captures an
h8 and now rook the g3 as this pawn is a
little bit weakened you kind of want to
have this option of maybe if the
position opens up shifting this rook
over to the b file uh so rook back to c8
by alireza and now king to e1 all right
we have to find a bit of a safer square
for our king we have b captures and c3 b
captures and now knight to e7 and now
alireza is preparing for for the end
game and this is how he does it king to
f1 and now this is the the beautiful
move king the a7 the problem is if you
play something like queen to beat you
and it seems like a move you really want
to play it's a very active move with the
queen not a lot for white to do the
problem is white has this bishop queen
to a6 move and um
it doesn't seem like you you you have
all that much to do here now that queen
remaining there is not an option and of
course if we capture some material then
it's an instant to draw by repetition
and of course something alireza wants to
avoid at all costs so here after king to
f1 we have king to a7 and now we prepare
to go into the end game with queen to a6
and claim that uh that um you know we
have a better better setup so here we
have rook to g1 uh and the queen to a6
offering a queen trade uh white obliges
we have queen captures an a6 king
captures and now bishop to d3 with check
we have king to a7 and now bishop to b5
and if you look at the position now this
is what alireza wanted uh he has two
pawn islands his opponent has three pawn
islands and of course uh or rather four
pawn islands so it's uh gonna be a
little bit easier for black to play this
as white has many weaknesses uh
realistically the only weakness in
black's camp is the f7 pawn which is the
base of the spawn chain and also the a5
pawn but it doesn't um
uh look like there there's a real way
for you to reach the a5 pawn uh the
bishop can't go after it it's it's a
light square bishop the the rook has you
know many many moves to reach the a5
pawn the knight could reach it with
something like knight c1 and knight here
but it will always be very easy for the
king to defend it so it's uh it's a
weakness but not one that white can
easily take advantage of so here the f7
pawn is the real weakness and the black
has that
covered very nicely with the bishop and
the knight guarding all of these squares
there's no way for white to lift the
rook so it's an equalish position you
know the material is equal but black is
definitely better here so knight's the
g8 alireza wants to play knight to f6
knight to e4 and put even more pressure
on the c3 pawn because this c3 pawn is a
weakness so rook g3 uh preparing to
defend that pawn and now knight to f6
uh white without really having any any
good moves here uh plays rook to d3 but
now knight's the e4 and now the problem
is uh even though yes uh it looks like
you're you're an opponent c3 is nicely
defended uh there's no good square for
your rook you can't really move the rook
if you play something like rook to f3 uh
then we simply win the rook knight uh
knight to d to check any other moves
also don't work if you play king to e1
uh the problem with king to e1 is we can
play knight d6 and now your rook is
blocking the bishop and we're just going
to capture that bishop for example king
to d1 we're going to capture it and
after this is captured we're going to
play king to b6 and now we're going to
capture this pawn and it's well that's
going to be game over very quickly so
instead after knight to e4 yeah erdog
tries rook to d1 uh he wants to give up
the c3 pawn but then the rook will have
to move from the back rank and then we
can bring our bishop to the bank rank
and go after this pawns
that are still on light squares so here
we have knight captures on c3 uh knight
captures and the rook captures on c3
followed by bishop to e8 of course we go
after this pawn so rook the c7 we have
to defend it but now this rook will be a
little bit passive if you want to
uh constantly have this f7 pawn defended
so now h4 error starts pushing uh the
past h pawn king to b7 uh we have rooked
the b1 check king to c8 and now even h5
continuing to push that pawn uh bishop
to g7 and now comes king to e2 we have
to bring our king into the game we have
king to d8 attacking the bishop and now
rook the b8 with check and now again if
already blocks this with the rook then
we can simply trade and after bishop
captures an f7 let's take into d7 and
it's a draw there's no winning this the
bishops are of opposite colors it's it's
an easy draw so after broke the ba to
check alireza has to move the king king
to e7 was played and now bishop back to
b5 and now you will be able to win back
your pawn with some like rook to a8 and
rook captures an a5 so indeed
the rook has reached the pawn so king to
f6 alireza starts improving the activity
of his king king to d3 white does the
same king g5 and now rook to a8 going
after this a5 pawn king captures on h5
we have rook captures on a5 and now king
the g4 so now alireza is still up upon
but white has this very dangerous past a
pawn
we have rook to a6 now comes king to f3
going after the pawn and now rook the c6
offering a trade here and you can't
really trade this if you trade this we
can just show it very quickly captures
captures and now of course we want to
queen our pawn here so the bishop has to
you know help out with the defense for
example a5 bishop d6 we're gonna go here
and then bishop b8 finally stops the
pawn from reaching the a7 square but now
bishop e8 goes after this spawn f6
bishop f7 goes after this pawn e5 and
now we can play captures captures and
then bishop captures on d5 with the
check
and this is now a draw if e4 with check
we can simply play king to d4
and now if king captures an f2 we simply
capture this captures captures and
captures and this is now a draw there is
no way uh for you to win this black will
simply put a bishop on a7 and then keep
his bishop on this diagonal once the
pawn is pushed to a7 we're going to give
up the bishop for the pawn and it is
going to be a draw by insufficient
material so after rook to c6 we have
rook to b7 now saying all right at least
you will not be pushing your past pawn
because the bishop is hanging and now
white has to be very very careful here
but here white played uh rook to c2 and
rook to c2 is a move that
is is unfortunately insufficient here
his idea is rook to c2 rook to b2 so the
bishop will be defended and then we can
start pushing our a pawn however this uh
doesn't really work uh we're gonna
discuss why it doesn't work but first
after rook the c2 was played uh feel
free to pause the video and try to find
the winning idea for alireza here while
i give you a couple of seconds
[Music]
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on spotting this
incredible incredible maneuver and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show it is of course bishop to f6 this
is the the the mood that wins and well
basically we need to we need to cover
this square and that's how uh that's how
this is one uh the the problem is with
rook the c2 that i said it we were going
to discuss uh rook the d6 is better for
the reason that after bishop to f6 you
you don't have to worry about such
things you just play rook to d7 and now
uh either the rooks get traded off the
board and then it's a draw i mean the
bishops are of opposite color uh or the
rook moves and then you can capture on
f7 which is still you know uh uh
droish but but maybe even
even better for for white who knows uh
this is the only way to play this for
white but after this rook the c2 was
played bishop to f6 now is a completely
different story uh rook the b2 was
played now preparing to push the a pawn
but now bishop to d8 stopping the the
push of the a pawn and now this bishop
is coming to a5 and after that you
really will not have all that much to do
with white uh so here you you don't have
uh like king c3 with some idea of bishop
to e2 to maybe
win the rook here with the discovery we
can just play this check and after king
b3 even f4 i mean black spawns are just
now uh completely dominant so instead
rook the c2 was played but it doesn't
help just bishop to a5 now comes rook to
c5 and uh that's all there there is
bishop to e1 now uh we're going to
capture the pawn with the bishop also
why this bishop maneuver was so
important because we don't really uh
have the option of capturing with the
king the rook was guarding that pawn on
the second rank but also we don't want
to give the white king any any free
square so it's better just to capture it
with the bishop then we're going to be
up two pawns and then we are completely
winning so here bishop to c6 attacking
galireza's rook rook to a7 and now
there's really nothing to do we're just
going to capture this spawn if you play
rook to sea to guard the pawn uh then
you've pretty much given up on all of
your all of your hopes i mean anything
can be played here we can even start
pushing f4 f6 e5 and it's not going to
be
um
easy for for white to hold this uh so
instead uh
erder decided to you know go out with a
bank he played rook to b5 uh sort of
giving up the a4 pawn and then trying to
trick alireza with rook captures on d5
but of course alireza does not fall for
this he sees that of course the pawn can
be captured rook captures on a4 is
played we have rook captures on d5 and
now of course we don't play captures and
captures but alexa just played rook to
a3 with check and it was in this
position on move 56 that victor erdog
resigned in the game as there is nothing
more to be done here
so a very very impressive uh uh game by
both of them but uh an even more
impressive victory for alireza i mean uh
the game had everything it had a very
very exciting opening then that uh you
know king walk king king to d7 to c7 to
b8 you know and then just
after castling you you open up your
king's position with b5 a5 starting for
the going for the attack and the white
held uh held his own definitely
throughout the entire game and it all
came down to this one moment where
instead of going for uh rook to d6 to d7
he played rook to c2 uh i'm pretty sure
erdog
spotted this possibility and knew that
it was an instant draw because the theme
you know repeats itself uh throughout
the game uh maybe he thought that this
was um
a winning attempt for white but he
missed that the bishop here will just be
uh incredibly incredibly strong and that
the bishop will also be able to go to e1
and pick up the f2 pawn so
really
uh really a tough tough loss for erdos
but a great victory for alireza who as
um i imagine you guys are very much
interested uh is making his way uh you
know into the into the top five or
rather he is in the top five he stopped
four now you can see that he is uh
uh
he's currently won uh 16.6 points uh
from the last period you know
when the points were added and he's
currently in number four so he needs
some five five five and a half points to
reach fabiana corona uh and then we will
see what happens next so
maybe it's possible even in this
tournament but we'll see you know it
requires a lot of winnings as he is uh
uh
uh uh much higher rated than than his uh
opponents here uh but yeah and also if
you guys just you know uh wanna check
out on how uh the ratings are you can
always just check it out it's the the
website 2700 chess so you can you know
enjoy some uh some live ratings not just
for classical but also you have for
rapid for blitz for juniors for you know
uh it's a good website uh so that's the
game hope you guys enjoyed it uh you
know it's uh
uh always a a pleasure to check up on
alireza and see how he how he's doing is
he already number one or rather number
two it's you know no one is catching up
to magnus anytime soon uh but yeah
that's it for this one yeah and uh i
would like to uh thank uh congrats dr
three uh dr theo coney uh dr b ranson
partner plus partner a.g francis ayer
james toyton and kevin hawkins for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it
as usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you for watching and i
will see you soon continuing the
coverage of this very nice event
checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world uh so thank you all i
will see you soon and have an excellent
rest of your day